[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if there's anything we know here at
Rotten Tomatoes it's movies and that
football is life and by football I mean
of course the type of football you play
with your feet football or soccer as we
like to call it here in the good old us
of a maybe a weekend Pastime for some
but globally it is the world's most
popular sport by a large margin
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with Arenas larger than Cathedrals and
the congregation of loyal fans in the
millions to fill them what better place
to capture the excitement heartbreak and
spectacle that has stopped Wars and
transcended borders then on the big
screen and with the World Cup just
around the corner we wanted to look at
the sport as seen on film
[Music]
thank you
dad
you'll see plenty of titles from
overseas as this beautiful game spans
Every Nation across the world so tie up
your boots and get on your kit as we
count down our list of the best soccer
movies
[Music]
number 10 the keeper
a young English woman and a soccer
playing German POW overcome Prejudice
public hostility and personal tragedy
near the end of World War II starring
David Cross Freya maver John Henshaw and
directed by Marcus H rosenmuller critics
say the keeper Strays into easy
sentimentality but this fact-based
drama's warm spirit makes its
indulgences easy to forgive
yes I wish
hey London in the goalsies
[Applause]
number nine Gregory's girl
Gregory Underwood is a graceless teen
soccer player on a hapless team when a
girl named Dorothy shows up to play
things change quickly Dorothy becomes a
top player while Gregory and the rest of
the team become enamored of her now
Gregory works up the courage to invite
Dorothy on a date she accepts but
Gregory finds that he's been deceived
into taking out another girl despite his
confusion Gregory eventually warms to
the situation starring John Gordon
Sinclair D Hepburn Jake Darcy and
directed by Bill Forsyth David dendy
from New York Magazine says Forsyth has
a very pleasing light touch the movie is
sweet lulling and often funny in all
perfect for young teenagers
I want a trial it's not possible dear
not today well we don't have a spare
ball
there's one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number eight Mario
Kung football players are caught between
the politics of the game and their
growing feelings for each other starring
Max hubacher Aaron altaras Jesse moravec
and directed by Marcel gizzler Kath
Clark from the guardian says at two
hours the film feels a little long but
this is a heartfelt in human drama with
the texture of Truth and characters to
care about
foreign
and
is
a roof
counselves
number seven early man
a Plucky caveman named Doug his sidekick
hognob and the rest of their tribe face
a grave threat to their simple existence
Lord knuth plans to take over their land
and transform it into a giant mine
forcing Doug and his clan to dig for
precious metals not ready to go down
without a fight Doug and hogna must
unite their people in an Epic Quest to
defeat a mighty enemy the Bronze Age
starring Eddie Redmayne Tom Hiddleston
Maisie Williams and directed by Nick
Park critics say early man isn't quite
as evolved as aardman's best work but
still retains the unique visuals and
sweet humor that have made the studio a
favorite among animation enthusiasts
foreign
caveman
[Music]
this may be an uneven contest that I am
but let's hope it's at least
entertaining let's get this done
[Music]
[Applause]
what
let's do it oh well this is interesting
very interesting
oh
[Music]
my God
number six the years my parents went on
vacation the year is 1970 and Morrow is
taken to live with his grandfather while
his mother and father flee the
politically repressive Brazilian regime
as the nation prepares to watch their
team compete in the soccer World Cup
Morrow anticipates the return of his
parents when his grandfather dies
suddenly he set adrift and befriends the
characters who live in the surrounding
Jewish neighborhood all the while
anxiously awaiting news of his parents
fate starring Michael Joel sauce germano
Hyatt Simone spoladore and directed by
cow hamburger critics say Hamburger
definitely refracts the socio-political
tumult of early 70s Brazil through the
lens of a young boy's coming of age and
Joel sauce's performance is wise Beyond
his years
let's go
today
why did you guys
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
number five looking for Eric
ever since his wife left him Eric
Bishop's life has fallen apart his two
teen sons have little regard for him his
job at the post office is increasingly
unfulfilling and he ends up in the
hospital after a car crash one night he
spokes marijuana and has a vision of his
favorite Manchester United soccer player
Eric Cantona with the help of his Idol
and his daughter Eric tries to get his
life straightened out starring Steve
evitt's Eric Cantona Stephanie bishop
and directed by Ken Loach critics say
Ken loach's latest is an uplifting
entertaining and amusing socio drama
featuring a match-winning performance
from Eric Cantona
foreign
no
come on say it
no
in French
no
no
like a minute
no
no
more more no
no
no
no
no
from your birth
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
[Music]
no
no
[Music]
dad
are you all right
no
number four Bend It Like Beckham
Jess Varma the daughter of a strict
Indian couple in London is not permitted
to play organized soccer even though
she's 18. when Jess is playing for fun
one day her impressive skills are seen
by Jules Paxton who then convinces Jazz
to play for her Semi-Pro team Jess uses
elaborate excuses to hide her matches
from her family while also dealing with
her romantic feelings for her coach Joe
starring Parminder nagra Archie Punjabi
Kyra Knightley and directed by grinder
Chata critics say inspiring
compassionate and with a Sly
undercurrent of social commentary Bend
It Like Beckham is a lively feel-good
movie that genuinely charms
and I was happy because I wasn't
sneaking off and lying to you
didn't ask to be good at football Guru
nanak must have blessed me
anyway there was a scout from America
there today and he's offered me a place
at a top university
with a free scholarship and a chance to
play football professionally
and I really want to go
and if I can't tell you what I want now
then I'll never be happy whatever I do
you let her leave her sister's wedding
to go to a football match
I'd handle her long face I could not
I didn't have the heart to stop us and
that's why she's ready to go all the way
to America now
number three Shaolin Soccer
all his life in ordinary young man has
been treated like dirt still he's never
given up believing that all the world's
problems could be solved with a little
Kung Fu so he's teaming up with a band
of Misfits six friends who were Kung Fu
Masters in their youth to form a soccer
team that only he believes has a chance
to win a one million dollar grand prize
together they're going to apply their
hidden talents to a whole new game and
soccer will never be the same starring
Wei Zao Yin SEI and Stephen Chow who
also directed the film with lilik Chi
critics say the plot is utterly
ridiculous and the soccer in the movie
is unlike any ever played anywhere on
Earth but watching Shaolin Soccer you
will probably find it impossible to care
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
number two the Damned United
the story of Brian close a 44-day sin as
manager of Leeds United Football Club
takes place in 1974 England when Don
Revy quits leads to become the England
boss the outspoken Brian klow takes
charge determined to impose his own
style upon revi's tough tackling team
Klaus soon alienates his players and the
board based on the book by David Pierce
starring Michael Sheen Timothy spall Jim
Broadbent and directed by Tom Hooper
critics say better than your average
football pick damned United is carried
by another star turn from Michael Sheen
as Brian klow
missing the target from there you want
bloody shooting now get in there that's
what I pay you for
170 grand for Colin Todd corrects in the
almighty Collins are the best technical
footballer in the country the salaries
will quit a week the cafe a footballer
that that's the way things are going
Uncle Sam football's all about money now
I told you never with over my head again
I have no choice Windows opened up you
were in the bloody West Indies windows
you mean there are others Mrs Gamo and
Hennessy oh
let me ask you a question Uncle Sam what
did you come into football for support
the football club of my hometown the pub
I've supported all my life well I'm sure
we all admire your loyalty what I didn't
come into it was we'd like to buy some
cocky little [ __ ] from the north east
the way I see it there's no point being
in this game unless you want to beat the
best and be the best and that's all the
people of Derby want and if you really
have their interest at heart not just
impressing your friends in the
director's box I suggest you keep your
eyes on your road haulage business keep
your opinions to yourself start signing
some fun checks there's a good lad leave
the loving of this football club to the
professionals
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Gracie
Gracie bone is the only girl among her
parents is four children her brothers
and father eat breathe and sleep soccer
and practice a sport every day when her
beloved older brother Johnny is killed
in a tragic accident Gracie attempts to
come to terms with her grief by
petitioning the school board to let her
take Johnny's Place on the boys varsity
soccer team starring Derma Mulroney
Elizabeth Shoe Carly Schroeder and
directed by David Guggenheim critics say
Gracie can be rousing and touching in
spots but is ultimately undone by its
predictable story arc and a lack of
nuance
you sat at the banquet you said go out
there and beat Kingston I didn't mean
you
good but not good enough
what are you talking about they're
riding up a corner no goalie nobody
blocking you there's nothing on it I
terrible shot you hit the post
it was a meatball my grandmother could
have knocked it down with her handbag
Peter Peter get out here you're playing
come on I want you one-on-one to the
goal you want to play soccer
don't go easy on me there's your ball
play ball
wide right
again
right now play ball
get around it
Ryan that's enough again we're gonna do
it come on show me
I said that's enough
underdogs
table soccer figurines come to life to
battle a bully who wants to destroy them
starring Ariana Grande Nicholas Holt
Matthew Morrison and directed by Juan
Jose Campanella Ian Freer from Empire
magazine says campanella's colorful
animation Jinx past its 2D characters to
bury one into the top corner or to put
it another way three stars
but I just can't
[Music]
like I was saying before the poor boys
nuts but a chicken
beautiful
baby
[Music]
chickens
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah
go
rudo e Kersey
are poor Step Brothers Living on a
banana plantation in Mexico both are
talented soccer players but their dreams
lay elsewhere tone deaf thought though
wants to be a singer while Beth though
is content to remain on the plantation
one day a sports agent sees the two
young men playing soccer and offers to
take one of them to Mexico City for a
chance at sports stardom starring Gail
Garcia Bernal Diego Luna Guillermo
francella and directed by Carlos cuaron
critics say despite its fair share of
sports movie cliches the beautiful game
marks an auspicious directing debut for
Carlos cuaron and features strong
performances from Garcia Bernal and Luna
foreign
foreign
offside
since women are banned from soccer
matches Iranian females masquerade as
males so they can slip into Tehran
Stadium to see the game between Iran and
Bahrain the ones who were caught and
arrested are taken to a holding area and
guarded by soldiers one sympathetic
Soldier agrees to watch the game through
a peephole and recount the action to the
impatient fans starring Seema
mobarakshai Safar samandar shayaste
Irani and directed by Jafar panahi
critics say a spirited film that
explores gender politics with comedy
intelligence and a variety of
interesting characters
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I am your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]